scuba diving at Devil's Den I love it
because it's just such an easy dive it's
great for beginners or Advanced divers
it's like going into another world
[Music]
hi I'm Kiki from live free diving and
we're here at the beautiful Devil's Den
so you pull up to beautiful Williston
and what's great about this location
it's fully equipped and they'll get you
all set up rental gear whatever you need
then we're gonna walk down to the picnic
tables and get set up
it's such a unique feeling because you
walk down this little stairs it's dark
at first and then once you go down it
just opens up to this like magical place
there's a ton of great places to scuba
dive in Florida
you've got to try scuba diving at the
Underwater Museum of Art
so the sculptures are located in Grayton
Beach on the Emerald Coast that has this
beautiful blue water so it's a great way
to mix up your traditional scuba diving
trip
[Music]
whether we're diving or beautiful
Florida Springs or offshore reefs
there's always something year round to
dive in Florida